hi I'm ex fans I'm Marc Webb director of  the Amazing Spiderman throughout the  process the goal was to make it totally  fun and large in life for the fans in  order to fully take advantage of the  IMAX experience the IMAX 3d presentation  will feature a larger aspect ratio and  select sequences which will fully  immerse fans into the world of  spider-man leading into a finale that  will blow you away  only one superhero was meant to be seen  in IMAX 3d Wow  Newsweek raves it's the best spider-man  yet  and gotta stop him  experience the stunning finale designed  exclusively for IMAX  the amazing spider-man rated pg-13  experience at an IMAX 3d is that I maxed  out comm for show times and listings